[Music]
indices party news oh damn
what party disease or disease party what
you thought I'd say Jesus sees like oh
sorry guys they both suck so whatever
eyes they read this but here we go
submitted by Michael from NZ like this
thank you parents are still using
chicken pox parties to expose their kids
to the virus
despite the CDC preferring back
vaccinations yeah Tyga just got back to
knit a did that to me when I was little
so he's not gonna get it
chickenpox yo if he does it's very mild
but he's not supposed to but he's still
doing it in lieu the vaccine what you do
is my mom did this when we were little
in Mexico so I have a sister who's three
years younger than I am and she got the
chicken pox and she was like wait you
haven't learned the chicken pox get in
the shower and then she showered us
together and then both of us were
running around with chicken pox that's
how my brother got me though yeah I have
a stuffed animal and then he had chicken
pox this [ __ ] was in high school - I
love up now though but he had chicken
pox in high school something like that
or junior high yeah he was older he was
older he rubbed my teddy bear all over
his body and he threw it at me of course
I caught it like an idiot and then I had
a most contagious I didn't even know
what the [ __ ] it was I was like an
elephant she's no but I heard that you
have to get it as a little kid because
as an adult like that yeah but once you
get it you're good so you can come back
as shingles right yeah why they want to
get rid of it actually yeah it's this
time chain you get it I think everyone
should experience chickenpox
pikas not gonna I was - it was not fun
you remember it I remember like it was
like four sounds like seven oh yeah I
was an elementary school I was like five
years old I got mono when I was nine
what is mono no I was such a germ freak
- I don't know what's mono it's it's
called the kissing disease but I was
such a germ freak I wouldn't even share
food or let anyone share lipgloss or
anything
yeah what's up I don't remember she
remember couldn't eat for like two we
couldn't eat I couldn't eat for two week
and I eat so I'm tebah chilly and I
couldn't be kabocha I know what that
means so yeah I just remember like I do
I couldn't move I was really hard to
move and the older you get like the
worse it is to so I was at least still
young but um but yeah I hadn't missed
two weeks of school and like I could
when I finally could eat again um or had
to eat those great Tylenol chewables but
I'm you old for them so I had to take a
lot of them and I couldn't swallow pills
I was awful and I couldn't eat great
flavor to anything but then ironically
my mom would the the first food I ate
was grapes she would cut them in half
though for me flavor and the flavor of
real grapes are definitely different
yeah yep so so yeah mono sucks and then
I got strep throat on top of the mono uh
what were you doing is your immune
systems dad
well were you kicking me away yeah yeah
the monkey bar handle you the drinking
fountains because those are prospective
[Applause]
kids like like licking I should do that
but like I always let it run a little
bit me too somebody you guys are weird
those are the crayon eating kids oh
happy
alright so chicken pox the vaccination
came out in 1995 and so that's when
people should have stopped doing these
chicken pox makes sense why I didn't get
it what oh you know yeah I had chicken
pox yeah
the natural way meat-eating of the best
around the same years when I got
chickenpox in 1995 damn you just missed
it dude well yeah so then um yeah so
they're finding out the share of these
private groups on Facebook where parents
are planning to use chicken pox parties
because of them whoa is it bad why is it
bad because well the CDC says it's
really bad because not everyone is gonna
have a mild case of chicken pox it was
pretty bad saying that there are out of
the 4 million chicken pox cases every
year
10600 lead to hospitalization and 150
end up dying Wow wait 150 out of them
out of out of 4 million a lot of people
I could have not liked it could have
been prevented
yeah like didn't happen if they got the
shot yes exactly so 100 the shot has a
hundred percent success rate um no but
they're saying like you get mild it's a
mild case of it so it's not gonna be
extremely instead of someone dying like
let's make this guy itchy no one dies if
they get the vaccination the way that
they wrote this is that those most as it
was as most of those deaths could have
been prevented by the vaccination that's
the way they worded it
so I guess 900 facts it's a high success
rate cuz 150 out of 4 million is it's
like one cent
that's not even that's really good from
a statistical standpoint but I think for
people that are trying to save their ass
they're like every child is a human
relationship ease vaccines costs I'm not
anti vaccine by the way it is a given I
don't know we haven't sure I just am
curious because it seems like a very low
rate oh I don't know I'm gonna assume I
would just you're like get it to that
party right yeah that's what's going
when you're low income at least in the
u.s. girl you get vaccinations if your
life with medica especially for kids
kids get everything for free I would
worry that it's not chickenpox like hey
my kid has chickenpox it's a party you
go and it's like [ __ ] shingles I mean
like or like black death or
this one kid got chickenpox because the
dad got shingles hmm what are shameless
it's like it's the same it's the same
thing well like what if what if it's not
even that it's like AIDS or some [ __ ]
why isn't it just called chickenpox for
adults I don't know no idea some fight
pleasant it's like oh maybe because when
chickens bite you it looks like that
like chicken pox
oh I don't know where the puffs come
from what is its box it's got smallpox
video chickens yeah you're asking the
wrong group of people when it comes to
diseases a medical [ __ ] we don't know
dad we don't know it's just smaller I'm
like some type on my kid with the other
kid or I think smallpox can actually
kill though rare but serious side
effects along the seams oh yeah smallpox
we got rid of right vaccines like really
deadly that's how the Europeans laid the
[ __ ] Native American stray slaves
stinky ass euros you're so nice
I don't know when there's a nice guest
that let me talk that's awesome okay so
side effects some rare situs yeah some
read yourself talk to some rare but
serious side effects associated with
chicken pox is include pneumonia
encephalitis which is swelling of the
brain bleeding problems bacterial skin
infections bloodstream infections which
is sepsis and death this sounds like
some beer mongering article to get
people to vaccinate your kids
during like like how much is these cost
like what's the if only a hundred fifty
out of four million it would seem like
it's not that much of an epidemic so why
tell you the truth people die off of
opioids on our way bigger rate than that
yeah it's just the fact that the CDC
doesn't endorse the natural immunity
method which is having these chicken pox
parties well I think if they want to
they could just say hey be aware of the
risks yeah well right so they are very
but the way they weight the way they're
writing it sounds like Big Pharma has
them here's some money
report this for me rather than here are
the options and here the risks of the
options make your own choice it's like
do you want a hundred and fifty kids to
die out of four million yeah that's how
it sounds like yeah yeah that's true
those lives could have been saved but
then it's like how many will most well
how much is most like 50 out of the 75
out of the hundred fifty yeah because
most people that's not that big of a
difference right they would be like well
yeah that's not really anything to worry
about because it's a hundred and fifty
out of four million like that's how they
would write the articles like it's not
that it's not that crazy from car crash
exactly what I from walking up smoking
drinking yes
yeah there's way worse things than this
sure and they write about those too but
they're just focusing here they give you
options and we when we had tyka like
they came in and they're like because
they know there's a lot of people that
are like anti vaccination so like hey do
you want to vaccinate your kid and then
me and you sound like Street we're like
xho kids are your kids vaccinated and
then the doctor like yeah my polio
epidemic coming back polio yeah because
people there's so many people not
vaccinating know that that polios like
coming back oh yeah with the remix like
that's a great depression of a beggar
that's like we learned this time
oh wait so what is polio exactly lose
that disease that um I've heard of I
don't know in it what something like
lost to the use of his legs but people
were dying from it all I mean like the
yes the Great Depression kind of thing
can gone ass legs remember that [ __ ]
yeah cuz like you might not have a kid
that survived oh well what is it do it's
like I don't know I don't know you lose
function of her leg you look you have
muscle atrophy oh one of her legs skip
leg day for your whole life and the
other one is [ __ ] mr. Olympia that's
what happened my uncle has Esha so I
know he has polio or you had polio and
M&E and uh man he got a swivel ass leg
dude uh [ __ ]
is it contagious so how do you get it I
don't know I just know a lot of people
had it let me Google yeah ignorant about
it because we haven't had it in so long
but now it's coming back we need to know
about it virus that may cause paralysis
and is easily preventable by the polio
vaccine
easily preventable oh we have a polio
party it's transmitted through natural
gas it is contagious so it says it's
transmitted through contaminated water
and food or contact with an infected
person so there actually might be polio
going around but then since we're immune
to it well we have a vaccine I guess
yeah if our ancestors got vaccinated
does that mean we're covered - no oh
[ __ ] you have to get it yourself why all
babies have to get vaccines because even
though we got on hand you're smart well
then there's so many non-zeroes on
scrunched in my bag because a polio of
many people who are infected they don't
become sick and have no symptoms however
those who do get sick develop paralysis
yep that's crazy
these ancient diseases many [ __ ] people
oh the plague came back thanks hell yeah
back yeah when buck there's certain
places now no no no I heard that
ceremony thing and this is just like
what I was oh yeah reading about where
they like there's a certain ritual they
do or they dance with the deceased and
yeah every bringing it back because they
dig them up yeah and they dance with
them as part of this ritual you know
what where let them RIPD country it was
like Indonesia or something like that it
was Morocco but then I went to Morocco
so maybe it wasn't rough I don't
remember I heard it was Antonio yeah it
was it was like a tribe in Indonesia or
something didn't literally bring people
up from like there or they mama fire
them and then they keep them somewhere
and then like when when it's time then
they come out and they dress them up and
then it's like yeah well yeah there's
all these old diseases black death yeah
yeah stuff that we had that we got rid
of coming back because polio I just do
what the doctors tell me got cocky the
doctor was like you know I darling oh
don't this [ __ ] GMO the [ __ ] out of my
kids
I'll [ __ ] GMO the [ __ ] out of them so
they stay petrified if that's how that
works
[Music]